В ефірі «heute journal»
з Крістіаном Зіверсом і Ханною Ціммерман.
Доброго вечора!
Для історії нашої планети 100 днів проходять, як мить,
але, якщо кожен день переповнений
болем, страхом і стражданням,
100 днів - це надто довго.
Загарбницька війна Росії в Україні
триває вже 100 днів -
і це ще не кінець.
Сьогодні в ефірі спробуємо розібратися:
що відбулося, що буде далі,
а що безповоротно змінилося -
для України, світу і Німеччини
за ці 100 днів війни.
Почнемо з кількох світлин:
ось, як виглядав театр у Маріуполі.
А це - те, що від нього лишилося.
Торговий центр у Києві - до початку війни і зараз.
Життя українців розділене на «до» і «після».
Ось місто Суми - знімки з повітря:
життя і апокаліптичний вигляд.
Що робить війна за 100 днів
- розповість Далія Антар.
Місто Маріуполь окуповане російськими військами.
Після 3-ох місяців облоги і обстрілів
над Маріуполем майорить російський прапор.
Валерія Мелікіна розповідає про втрати
біля «братської» могили, де похований і її чоловік.
«Тіла лежать одне на одному, у 8 шарів,
по три тіла поряд»
Що робить стоденна війна
з країною та її жителями?
ООН говорить про такі втрати:
вбито 4169 мирного населення, з них 268 дітей.
Очевидно, що реальна кількість жертв є набагато вищою.
Також і тисячі вбитих солдат.
Близько 8 млн українців - внутрішні переселенці,
а більше 6,8 млн виїхали за межі України.
Озирнемося назад: 24 лютого 2022 року
російські війська вторглися в Україну.
Мета – взяти Київ і повалити вище керівництво держави.
Уся країна - під обстрілами Росії.
Але просування російських військ
на півночі зупинилося.
Міць українських військових підрозділів
явно недооцінила не лише Росія.
Очевидно, що українські війська зреагували ефективніше,
аніж неповоротка російська армія.
Україна готувалася.
Київ замовив у Туреччини нові боєздатні дрони,
які зіграли важливу роль
для успішних військових дій української армії.
Російська армія відходить з півночі України.
Захоплення Донбасу стає пріоритетним завданням.
Міста, з яких відійшли російські війська, розкриють
світові воєнні злочини російської армії.
Як-от Буча. І це далеко не єдине місто,
де російські війська вчиняли воєнні злочини.
Лише зараз Росія досягла деяких стратегічних цілей,
наразі вона контролює 20% території України,
як-от важливі міста Маріуполь і Херсон.
Росія не залишає планів захопити Харків, Одесу і Київ.
У 100-ий день виснажливої війни зрозуміло,
що ці 100 днів - це 100 днів страждань, руйнувань,
але і 100 днів боротьби та незламності духу.
Занадто багато подій, історій, облич,
які закарбувалися у пам'яті за останні 100 днів.
Вони не залишають нас байдужими.
Ні вдома, ані тут, у студії.
Перехоплює подих від подій і вражень,
бо на те, чим ми ділимося з Вами,
важко дивитися спокійно.
Зараз в Україні для нас працює Йоганнес Гано і
далі його репортаж про події в України на 100-ий день війни.
Ми їдемо по Миколаївській області,
приблизно за 30 км від лінії фронту.
На перший погляд - тиха сільська місцевість
на півдні України.
Ми хочемо зрозуміти, як війна змінює людей.
Багато з них вже пережили чимало.
Марія народилася у трудовому таборі в Граці.
Нацисти примусово вивезли її батьків.
Я таке вже пережила, коли була малою.
Ніколи б не подумала, що доживу до того дня,
що на старості доведеться мені на війні побувать.
Міський голова Баштанки показує нам,
як може змінитися життя людей
за одну мить, за один удар з неба.
250-кілограмові бомби повільно
спустилися на парашутах.
Вони знищили все.
Він такого потужного вибуху навіть
у сусідньому населеному пункті повибивало вікна.
Бомбовий терор проти мирного населення.
Мешканцям сусідніх сіл,
котрі змушені були полишити рідні домівки
через російських окупантів,
надають найнеобхідніше.
Як кажуть самі люди: у них забрали їхнє життя.
Байдуже, наскільки буде важко.
Коли ми повернемося додому,
ми все відбудуємо.
У будь-якому випадку, ми вернемося у рідні домівки, до себе.
Всі мешканці села прагнуть потрапити додому
і сподіваються,
що такі чоловіки, як Ігор, допоможуть у цьому.
З цією гаубицею часів СРСР
чоловіки ідуть на війну проти російських військ.
Однак вони хотіли б мати кращу техніку.
З кожним роком зброя стає більш модернізованою,
а ця гаубиця з 1986 року повністю застаріла.
Ігор сподівається, що незабаром
зможе познайомитися з новою технікою,
яку пообіцяла Німеччина.
Для Михайла та Ольги -
сьогодні дуже особливий день.
Михайлові дали тимчасове звільнення.
Його син Андрій з кількома товаришами
приїхали прямо з поля бою, щоб привітати батька.
Батько та син воюють в одній бригаді
на південному фронті.
У ці важкі для України часи кожен
повинен робити те, що він може,
і це цілком нормально,
коли батько і син чи брати разом воюють на фронті.
Це свідчить про нашу єдність і незламність.
Андрій та його друзі не залишаються на святкуванні,
вони потрібні на фронті.
Для Ольги та Михайла це вже другий шлюб.
Ольга розповідає нам,
що щаслива знову знайти чоловіка,
який підтримує її і буде з нею,
хоча наразі - ненадовго,
бо Михайлові потрібно повертатися на фронт.
Альтернатив в нас немає.
Ми станемо сильною, гарною і могутньою країною.
Віра і воля до боротьби -
це тримає людей в єдності і допомагає не опускати рук,
навіть після 100 днів війни.
1 вересня 1939 року газета «New York Times»
опублікувала на першій сторінці великими літерами:
Німеччина напала на Польщу.
Початок Другої світової війни.
Через 100 днів після цієї публікації
на перших шпальтах газети вже зовсім про інше:
переслідування злочинців та різні спортивні змагання.
Зникаючий інтерес до теми,
котра раніше була у всіх на вустах -
явище досить знайоме.
Це самозахист, первісний інстинкт,
але він може завести у пастку,
адже виклики нікуди не поділися.
Сьогодні Бундестаг затвердив
зміни до Конституції Німеччини,
щоб уможливити мільярдні інвестиції
для Бундесверу.
Ще один знак,
наскільки вже змінилася наша країна.
Репортаж Томаса Райхарта.
Достатньо глянути на трибуни,
щоб зрозуміти, про що говорять у Бундестазі.
Одягненого у військово-польовий костюм
Голову Верховної Ради України
зустрічають оплесками стоячи.
Майже стільки ж підтримки отримує Бундесвер,
майбутнє якого вирішується зараз.
Цей день показує, настільки змінилася країна
з моменту проголошення промови
Шольца про «час змін», в якій
він несподівано заявив про Спеціальний фонд для Бундесверу.
Федеральний бюджет на 2022 рік передбачає
суму 100 млрд євро для Спеціального фонду.
Ми використаємо ці кошти
на оснащення армії.
Для ухвалення рішення про Спеціальний фонд
знадобилося цілих 3 місяці.
Союз CDU/CSU підтримав рішення.
Незважаючи на
гострі обговорення і розбіжності
таки вдалося досить швидко знайти консенсус.
Ми надаємо Бундесверу додаткові кошти в 100 млрд євро.
Говорячи чесно, це і додаткові борги,
а не додатковий фонд з доходів.
Навіть FDP голосує за те, щоб
через зміни до Конституції
відійти від принципу «боргового гальма».
Також і Зелені, які традиційно виступали за роззброєння,
наполягають на модернізації зброї.
Хоча Зелені трохи і незадоволені,
їм не вистачає інвестицій у кібербезпеку
і розвиток оборонної співпраці у Європі.
Навіть, якщо рішення про Спеціальний фонд
є не настільки далекоглядним,
воно все одно не менш важливе.
Ми не повинні гаяти ані секунди з модернізацією Бундесверу.
Винищувачі «Торнадо» в експлуатації уже 40 років,
їх замінять сучасними
бомбардувальниками-«невидимками» F35.
Також транспортний гелікоптер
CH53 в експлуатації 50 років
замінять на новий боїнг CH47 «Чінук».
Заміна техніки, яку відкладали десятиліттями.
Багато чого змінюється.
Поглянемо у минуле на нацистський мілітаризм,
який завжди був застереженням,
а тепер озброєння стало зобов'язанням.
У ті часи в Європі боялися
військової могутності Німеччини.
Сьогодні ж в Європі побоюються,
що Німеччина має дефіцит військової техніки
і немодернізовану армію.
Партія AfD підтримує інвестування,
але не схвалює шлях фінансування.
Партія Лівих взагалі не підтримує створення Фонду.
На що тільки можна було б витратити 100 мільярдів!
Пані Бербок, Ви також хвилюєтесь за долі дітей
та хочете боротися з дитячою бідністю.
Чому для боротьби з дитячою бідністю
не створили спеціальний фонд?
Сьогодні проголосувати треба було двічі:
за внесення поправок до Конституції Німеччини
та за створення фонду на 100 млрд євро.
З понад двома третинами голосів ухвалили
обидві пропозиції.
Парламент зараз неначе утверджує «історичні зміни»,
про які говорив Шольц.
Конфліктолог та соціальний психолог Андреас Цік
із Білефельдського університету
розглядає вплив війни на суспільство.
Пане професоре, добрий вечір.
Добрий вечір, пане Зіверс.
Ми почули політичне поняття «історичні зміни»,«час змін».
Що це означає з військового погляду
ми щойно також почули,
все досить зрозуміло.
Йдеться про суму у 100 млрд євро.
Чи достатньо просто так використовувати цей термін?
Яким змістом наповнений цей «час змін»
для Німеччини?
Ні, я думаю, що цього не достатньо.
Варто розглядати термін «час змін» у контексті,
розуміти, де і коли його вжили.
27 лютого цього року канцлер сказав,
що час змін настав через розірвання договорів,
через вторгнення,
через напад Росії на Україну та розв'язання війни.
Отже, у промові йшлося про те,
що час змін спровокувала Росія.
На мою думку, багато громадян та громадянок
зараз також вважають, що нам потрібен
власний активний «час змін».
А що ж сказав Олаф Шольц?
Тоді канцлер сказав,
що зараз ми маємо обстоювати вільну, відкриту,
справедливу та мирну Європу.
Йдеться про 5 основних елементів:
свободу, відкритість кордонів, також і про міграцію,
справедливість, а також про мир,
тобто спосіб забезпечення миру,
і про Європу.
Це - 5 величезних проєктів.
Ба більше, ми очікуємо на зміни також і в інших сферах.
Ми чули про зміни клімату,
що очікують на нас у майбутньому.
Ми бачимо, що у країні зростає соціальна нерівність,
яка буде відчутною.
Тому зараз варто скласти політичну програму,
що охоплюватиме повністю ці проблеми,
що прокладе шлях до майбутнього Німеччини в Європі.
Я спочатку зупинюсь на тому,
що Ви сказали наприкінці.
Цей час змін охоплює,
принаймні на мій суб'єктивний погляд,
значно більше викликів нашого часу.
Ви їх зазначили: зміна клімату, коронавірус.
Ці конфлікти неначе розтягуються в часі,
а зараз ще й витісняються
іншим великим конфліктом - війною.
Чи безпечно це для суспільства?
Ні, це не є безпечним, коли ми не захищені
від конфліктів.
Тобто ми маємо реагувати превентивно.
Ми переживаємо багато соціальних конфліктів.
Ми пережили економічну та фінансову кризу.
Потім був масовий наплив мігрантів,
швидко визнаний кризою.
Потім ми пережили пандемію,
до якої не були добре підготовлені.
У момент, коли виникають кризи,
суспільство потрапляє у режим конфлікту.
Ми пережили жахливе посилення популізму,
що також вплинуло на суспільство.
Політичні дискусії також стали більш популістськими.
Недовіра до демократії також зросла в Німеччині.
За даними наших досліджень, минулого року
приблизно 25% населення вважає,
що демократія призводить
до поганих вимушених компромісів.
Ми пережили те, що верхівка правління
також намагалася
встановити сильніше та авторитарніше управління,
ґрунтуючись на авторитарних елементах.
Ба більше, кризи з'являються під час кризи.
Війна, яка триватиме довго, може призвезти
до нових конфліктів,
бо війна потребує значного фінансування,
а суспільство і Європу треба перебудовувати.
Треба думати більш превентивно.
Треба превентивно реагувати на популізм, екстремізм,
на терор, що виникає зараз.
Треба також думати про те, як зробити політику
більш зрозумілою,
як пояснювати ті чи інші заходи.
Якщо, наприклад у часи пандемії, політика не пояснює
вживання тих чи інших заходів, ми не розуміємо,
що на нас чекає,
тоді це лише підкріплює популізм та екстремізм.
Над цим ми і маємо зараз працювати.
Ви вже згадали декілька вимог:
треба бути більш відкритим, більш прозорим,
більше пояснювати.
Ви згадали багато негативних моментів.
Але була і залишається велика солідарність
з боку німців.
Особливо щодо людей, яким довелося
евакуюватися з України.
Але і занепокоєння в Німеччині досить відчутне.
Що саме необхідно для того, щоб цей «час змін»
мав позитивний результат?
І бажано для всіх.
На мою думку, зараз досить відчутним є те,
що громадяни хочуть бути залученими до прийняття рішень.
Питання залученості громадян досить важливе
і для Європи.
Запобігання насильству - це важливе питання.
Безпека - це сильне громадянське суспільство,
яке самостійно може впоратися з популізмом та екстремізмом.
Політична комунікація, наприклад, знову ж таки у часи пандемії,
має бути набагато прозорішою, чіткішою,
на що політикам потрібно більше часу.
Це означає, що нам також потрібні
інші канали комунікації.
І ми повинні ставитися до цього серйозно.
Ми живемо у часи цифровізації,
інформаційний простір переповнений
повідомленнями щодо теорій змови
та фейковими новинами.
Це обговорювали і щодо теми «кібербезпека».
Потрібно вибудовувати захист від фейкових новин.
Ми можемо покладатися на громадян,
тому що вони демонструють величезне бажання
допомагати в такі кризові часи,
вони демонструють культуру гостинності.
І ця культура, свідками якої ми зараз є,
має залишатись і надалі.
Її треба просувати.
І її можна спрямувати в громадянську активність.
Цю культуру можна було відчути під час повеней,
під час імміграції біженців.
Це функціонує, а наше завдання - визначити як саме,
і зробити суспільство підготованим до конфліктів,
тобто до нових спалахів екстремізму та популізму.
Війна нам доводить, наскільки великий вплив
може мати навіть державний популізм ﻿та екстремізм.
Ми можемо досягти набагато більшого.
Ми лише маємо зміцнити громадянське суспільство
у певний спосіб.
Величезні виклики та величезна робота попереду.
Пане професоре, щиро дякую за розмову.
З нами на зв'язку був професор Андреас Цік
із Білефельдського університету.
Дякую.
Ханна розповість нам про інші важливі новини.
Голова Верховної Ради України Руслан Стефанчук
зараз перебуває у Німеччині
і сьогодні зустрівся з канцлером Олафом Шольцем.
Під час зустрічі у Відомстві Канцлера
Руслан Стефанчук наголосив на важливості
швидкого постачання обіцяної зброї.
Він також запросив Олафа Шольца до Києва,
щоб виступити у Верховній Раді України.
Олаф Шольц «взяв запрошення дружньо до відома»,
як відзначив речник уряду.
Африці загрожує катастрофічна продовольча криза.
Причиною цьому є неможливість
експортування зерна
через війну в Україні.
З цієї причини Голова Африканського Союзу
та Президент Сенегалу Макі Салл
зустрівся сьогодні з Президентом Росії
Володимиром Путіним.
Зокрема, Макі Салл вимагав зняти
експортну блокаду
українських морських портів.
За словами Салла, Африка повністю залежить
від ситуації, що склалася.
Росія ж звинувачує західні санкції
у відсутності експорту зерна.
Майже 496 мільярдів євро -
саме таку суму дозволено витратити
уряду Німеччини цьогоріч.
Сьогодні у Бундестазі переважною більшістю голосів
ухвалили бюджет на 2022 рік.
Через загарбницьку війну в Україні
та пандемію COVID-19
також передбачаються нові боргові зобов'язання
у розмірі приблизно 139 млрд євро.
Для цього депутати призупинили дію закріпленого
в Конституції «боргового гальма»,
тобто заборони здійснювати нові структурні запозичення.
Бундестаг також ухвалив рішення щодо підвищення
встановленої законом мінімальної заробітної плати
за яке проголосували партія Лівих
та «світлофорна коаліція».
З 1 жовтня працівники мають отримувати
не менше 12 євро за годину.
Федеральний міністр праці Губертус Гайль зазначив,
що для багатьох це буде
«найбільшим підвищенням зарплати
у їхньому житті».
Підвищення отримають понад 6 млн працівників.
Водночас підвищиться і максимальний розмір зарплати
для «мінізайнятостей»:
з 450 до 520 євро.
Сьогодні в Бундестазі ухвалили ще одне рішення,
важливе для мільйонів пенсіонерів:
пенсії будуть збільшені - і значно.
З 1 липня їх збільшать на 5,35%
у Західній Німеччині
та на 6,12% у Східній Німеччині.
Міністри та міністерки внутрішніх справ
уряду та земель
планують покращувати якість цивільної оборони
та боротьби зі стихійними лихами.
Тому землі вимагають від уряду Німеччини
більшого фінансування, а саме:
10 млрд євро впродовж наступних 10 років.
У майбутньому експертний центр відповідатиме
за координування та розподіл ресурсів
у кризових ситуаціях.
Ще однією важливою темою зустрічі
була боротьба з насильством над дітьми, яка
за рішенням зустрічі, має бути посилена.
Крім того, було вирішено оперативніше видаляти
матеріали, що зображують сексуальне насильство.
Регіональний потяг переповнений.
Надворі чудова погода, а це - найпопулярніший регіон
для екскурсій.
Останній шкільний день перед канікулами
на День Святої Трійці.
А потім трапляється нещасний випадок, який
тепер терміново розслідують:
потяг раптово перевернувся.
В результаті  у вагонах загинуло щонайменше
4 людини. Багато отримали поранення.
Після такого потрясіння завжди виникають питання,
і цього разу їх так багато, як ніколи.
Також тому, що цей нещасний випадок
продовжує сумну серію схожих.
Таких серйозних залізничних аварій
за останні декілька років відбулося особливо
багато в Баварії.
Детальніше розповість про це Зімон Пфанцельт.
Очевидно, що в потязі було багато школярів,
коли близько 12 години трапилася аварія.
Вже через дві хвилини перші рятувальники прибули на місце
аварії.
Нещастя, в яке важко повірити.
Коли розумієш, що більше не можеш допомогти певній людині,
тому що це неможливо через ситуацію,
оскільки вона застрягла в пастці  під поїздом.
Важко прийняти свою нездатність щось зробити.
Потяг рухався у бік Мюнхена лише кілька хвилин.
Близько 140 осіб були у потязі,
коли численні вагони з'їхали з колії.
Щонайменше чотири людини загинули,
ще 30 отримали поранення.
12 осіб станом на вечір пропали безвісти.
На місці працювало 120 одиниць техніки рятувальної служби,
230 рятувальників та 8 гелікоптерів.
Пожежні частини були там із сотнями працівників
екстрених служб,
оскільки ситуація була дуже заплутаною.
За словами свідка, потяг просто перевернувся.
Це було жахливо.
Чому так сталося, незрозуміло й досі.
До розслідування залучено багато слідчих
відділів нашої кримінальної поліції.
Їх викликали і зараз вони працюють тут,
аби якомога швидше з'ясувати причини аварії.
Трагедія викликає багато питань.
На перший погляд, картина нагадує
аварію в Бад-Айблінзі,
де у 2016 році зіштовхнулися
два пасажирські потяги.
Або ж аварію в Шефтларні,
де кілька місяців тому зіткнулися два
потяги наземного метро S-Bahn.
Але сьогодні в Гарміші
не було другого потягу в аварії.
За словами поліції,
розслідування може тривати довго.
У Берліні перед камерами зустрічаються міністр
транспорту Віссінґ
та генеральний директор «Deutsche Bahn» Лутц.
Сьогодні і вони не змогли відповісти на питання
«Чому так сталося?».
Ми в тісному контакті з рятувальними службами.
І допомагаємо тим, чим можемо.
Наші фахівці на місці і разом з поліціянтами
з'ясовують причини аварії.
Сьогодні не той день, аби будувати припущення
щодо причин аварії.
З цим розбиратимуться слідчі органи.
Ввечері міністерка внутрішніх справ Німеччини
Фезер
навідалася до місця аварії, аби дізнатися
про перебіг рятувальних робіт.
Вони можуть тривати ще декілька днів.
І всі сподіваються, що більше не знайдуть
мертві тіла
під вагонами потягу.
З нами Ютта Зонневальд з місця аварії.
Питання щодо причин:
чи вдалося наблизитись до відповіді
та чи вже з'ясували причини, що можна виключити?
Можна виключити зіткнення
з іншим потягом.
Оскільки це залізничне сполучення є одноколійним.
Крім того, аерофотознімки поліції показують,
що на цій ділянці траси не було й переводу стрілок.
Поліція також виключає можливість нападу,
пов'язаного із проведенням саміту G7 в кінці місяця  в замку неподалік.
Можливо, підказку зможе дати машиніст потягу,
який, на щастя, вижив.
Однак не відомо,
чи він поранений і наскільки серйозно,
та чи можна буде його допитувати.
Спеціальна слідча група детальніше вивчатиме
несправність потягу та цю залізничну ділянку.
З'ясування точних причин аварії
може тривати місяцями.
І ми знову повертаємося до сьогоднішньої теми -
100 днів війни.
Тепер з точки зору економіки.
Відповіддю Європейського Союзу на
загарбницьку війну Росії
протягом останніх кількох тижнів
стали економічні санкції.
І шостий пакет санкцій включає
розширене нафтове ембарго,
яке офіційно затвердили сьогодні країни ЄС.
Штефані Барретт у Франкфурті.
Проте головне питання наступне:
що взагалі дають санкції?
Вони ще досі не змогли зупинити війну.
Санкції дійсно впливають на Росію,
але перш за на її звичайних громадян.
Вони воюють на всіх фронтах зі зростанням цін,
і це попри те, що Росія вже стала більш незалежною
в багатьох сферах
після санкцій, пов'язаних з окупацією Криму.
Однак не весь імпорт із Заходу можна замінити
так швидко,
вирощування фруктів та овочів
теж на низькому рівні.
Ціна на макарони, хліб і олію помітно зросла,
цукор коштує на 40% більше
в порівняні з минулим роком.
Високий рівень цін зіштовхується з низьким рівнем
заробітних плат
та пенсій.
Більшість росіян працює в державному секторі,
а отже не так гостро сприймає
дистанціювання від Заходу.
«McDonalds» та багато інших брендів залишили
територію країни,
в торговельних центрах багатьох міст Росії
переважають пусті вітрини.
Ймовірно, західні товари замінюватимуться
на російську продукцію:
не тільки російська «кола», а й локальна
мережа фаст-фуду
скоро розпочнуть свою роботу.
Усе-таки Росія сильно залежить від імпорту.
Економісти переконані в тому,
що промисловість РФ повністю зіштовхнеться
із глобальними наслідками санкцій
лише за кілька місяців.
Нині через дефіцит особливо страждає аерокосмічна
та автомобільна промисловості.
Через дефіцит деталей
в автопромисловості знижують стандарти,
наприклад, в категоріях викидів та безпеки:
від подушок безпеки вже відмовилися.
Відповідно до останніх даних експорту,
в економіці Німеччини
сьогодні можна побачити передвісники
реорганізації ﻿світової торгівлі:
стабільно зростає експорт в США,
експорт товарів до Китаю навпаки спадає,
а торговельні відносини з Росією мінімізуються.
Дякую, Штефані, за ці дані.
Сполучене Королівство святкує цими днями
70-річчя правління на престолі
королеви Єлизавети II.
Сьогодні відбулося подячне богослужіння у соборі
Святого Павла у Лондоні.
Однак Королева не була присутня через
«погане самопочуття».
Замість неї на службі був її син Чарльз.
Принц Гаррі та його дружина Меган
викликали фурор.
Вони відвідали офіційний королівський захід вперше
після виходу з королівської родини.
А тепер про теніс та драматичний вихід
Александра Зверєва з півфіналу
Відкритого чемпіонату Франції з тенісу.
Сьогодні його супернику Рафаелю Надалю
вдалося зупинити олімпійського чемпіона.
Поразка не може бути більш болючою.
Александр Зверєв хотів вдруге вийти у фінал
турніру GrandSlam в Парижі,
та вперше виграти головний турнір.
Зрештою, він покинув корт «Stade Roland Garros»
на милицях.
Його суперник Надаль може в 14 раз виграти
Відкритий чемпіонат Франції.
Він щасливий, що вийшов до фіналу
на своє 36-річчя,
водночас співчуває своєму опонентові.
Я бачив, як він плакав у роздягальні,
це був дуже прикрий момент.
Я можу лише побажати всього найкращого йому
та його команді.
До отримання травми, Звєрєв показав
високі результати в грі високого класу.
На тай-брейку першого сету у нього чотири сет-пойнти.
Але Надалю вдається майже неможливе.
Нарешті іспанець виграв тай-брейк з рахунком 10:8.
В другому сеті обидва грали нарівні
та відбили обидва 4 рази подачі суперника.
Однак драматична сцена,
що відбулася коли рахунок був 5:6,
стала фатальною для Зверєва.
Звєрєв падає і з криками болю лежить на корті,
до нього підвозять візок.
Про характер і тяжкість травми
поки що нічого не відомо.
Надаль гратиме у фіналі проти норвежця Каспера Рууда.
Таким був наш світ в цю п'ятницю.
Ми рекомендуємо вам подивитися
«heute journal up:date»
о 23:55 з Назан Гокдемір.
До завтра, гарного вам вечора.
Доброго вечора. На Трійцю буде гроза.
Завдяки південно-західному фронту
сьогодні опівдні будуть перші грози.
Тут дуже добре видно, що ці хмари
відійшли від Німеччини.
Протягом останніх 3 годин
все одно були сильні грози,
особливо на кордоні з Чехією.
Цей циклон, який приніс грози, рухається на Схід,
але за ним наближається наступний з Франції
на неділю Трійці.
Сьогодні ще будуть грози, проте не на Півночі.
Температура знизиться до 12-16°.
Завтра найвищі температури очікують нас
на узбережжі морів - 16-20°.
На середньому та верхньому Рейні температура
становитиме 21-27°.
Завтра буде найясніший день святкових вихідних.
Є загроза злив та гроз в Айфелі.
На Трійцю очікуються пориви вітру та грози
по всій території Німеччини.
Обов’язково подивіться на небо,
якщо маєте плани.
Північного Сходу непогода не досягне.
На Сході в неділю на Трійцю буде дуже сонячно.
Після свят грози поступово вщухатимуть.
Гарного вечора.